hi this is Carrie Underwood and here's a
behind-the-scenes look from my new music
video today we are out in Asheville it's
a two-day shoot and round
[Music]
I have worked with Shane right before
his vibe his energy he is a very
energetic director we all felt like he
would just be such a great fit for this
song in this video and I know this going
to make it
[Music]
we really wanted to drive our pointer
[ __ ] about just different people and
different coming from different places
and got a big diverse amazing group of
people that all live in Nashville
these different festivals and stuff like
that like around the world kind of
celebrating unity and love they use
these paints at the end of the festival
you can't tell anything about anybody
there are no defining characteristics
about anybody and by the end of tonight
we will all look the same
and won't know where we were coming from
or where we're going we're just gonna be
one big total mess
[Music]
that is a wrap on the winds video
you
[Music]